the White House is watching the
presidential election in Turkey which
could have a big impact on the U.S and
its NATO allies voters went to the polls
yesterday after a natural disaster and
an economic collapse put the country's
longtime leader under heavy pressure
president erdogan is claiming success
this morning but he's expected to face a
runoff election later this month Remy
and ascencio has more on the future of
this important U.S partner
[Music]
Turks by the thousands waved Flags
and cheered a seemingly triumphant
president reject erdogan did you know
that we've already surpassed our closest
competitor by 2.6 million votes he said
but these party songs may be too soon
twin earthquakes in February that killed
more than 50 000 people inflation near
two decade highs and a currency that's
crashed against the dollar have shaken
one seemingly Invincible support for
erdogan he came to power in 2003 more
people than ever now want change arduan
elections are not one on the balcony
data is still coming in said opposition
candidate Kamal kirch.oroglo he could
still be president a record number of
votes 1.8 million are also being counted
critics say erdogan has amassed too much
power as president diluted democracy and
derailed secularism on which the country
was founded supporters say he has
brought Islam back both men have agreed
to a runoff if needed held in two weeks
for Washington and much of Western
Europe an Open Secret the end of erdogan
would be their new Turkish delight for
CBS morning's raymie inocencio London